Russian forces in eastern Ukraine have
launched a new assault with thousands of
troops according to British defense
officials the latest battle is on top of
the continued fighting in the eastern
city of Baku which has already been
largely destroyed in months of tax
Deborah patta visited the front lines
where Ukrainian forces are using
everything they've got including
surveillance drones to keep control of
that City
is barely recognizable nearly a year of
War has left the city once renowned for
sparkling wine a hollowed-out shell
but mod still holds is the Ukrainian
battle crime but only just the sound of
artillery is constant this city has been
decimated and it's deserted wiring a few
people still trying to eke out some kind
of living here
even a trip to the Central Square is
done with one eye on the clock
the other on the sky
Cartier commanders
Battalion is helping to prevent Russia
from seizing the city come on come on
much of that battle is directed in
underground high-tech command centers
like this where soldiers use drones to
live stream video from the front line
revealing it in astounding detail like
this dead Russian soldier and shattered
backyards where Russian troops were
recently filmed crawling for cover their
monitoring of the videos and as soon as
they see
the enemy there or the tanks or
something else they just start to shoot
World War one trench warfare meets 21st
century electronic surveillance
games are counted in inches with Russia
throwing waves of soldiers like meat
into the fight we're told
they just keep on advancing over the
bodies of their fallen soldiers third
operative Battalion Commander Anton Zara
rogini said one group is destroyed
another sent in the main work sleep and
eat here in shifts around the clock no
job too menial making sure for now that
on the blood-soaked battlefields just a
few blocks away
still holds for CBS mornings Deborah
patter bakmud